وما اجمل من ان تبث الروح بوقتك وانا
اخترت بمسائل العربيه وطبعا بفقره افطار
ما ان يكون افطار مع الناس وافطار من اجل
الناس وانا متواجده بمطعم
واطلق من هنا مبادره اعطي من وقتك وراح
اعطي من وقت اليوم واهتم برواد المطعم
وطبعا اليوميه كامله وحتى الاكراميه سيتم
التبرع فيها لهيئه الاعمال الخيريه
العالميه ومشروعهم المتعلق بكفاله الايتام
في فلسطين ورائد شكرا كتير لالكم احنا
مبسوطين كتير فيكي ميسون جيتوا لعنا احنا
رح نتمنى المبادره من كل جوانبها واحنا من
هون حنعطيك تيشيرت اعطي من وقتك
وحنتوقع
باناس بنطلع من الناس لكفاله اليتامى احنا
حنحط قدهم
عشان ندعم المبادره ونكون معكم
هلا اجا دورنا لنتعلم فن المهني
شو لازم اعمل بس اهم شيء بتحطي
على الطاوله هيك
ونرحب بالناس اهم شيء الابتسامه في رمضان
كريم طيب ولا معصبين زي المصور باسل وسامر
شو بعمل فيهم ابتسامه حلوه رمضان كريم طيب
انا صايمه
شو اعمل عصير وتم بعدين الشغل على طول وقد
بدا العد العكسي يلا
[موسيقى]
عنا برنامج مسائل العربيه اللي هو بالاصل
صباح العربيه عاملينه بالمسف عاملين شغله
اسمها افطار معك فانا قررت تكون افطار مع
الناس وافطار من اجل الناس فموجوده هون
لاخدم اليوم والراتب اللي راح يطلع معي
واي ست اذا لقيته سيرفس تاعي منيحه بتروح
لتشرطي لكفاله ايتام بفلسطين طبعا اختي
اصرت انه روز تيجي روز المربيه عندي
بالبيت فاليوم هي المدام وانا ام سيرفين
اختي حبيبه قلبي رنا اجت مع فريق عملها
كاملا اضافه لبنتي جنى ورفيقتها سلمى
ليدعموني
كان يوم طويل بس كان جميل ومردودو ولا
اجمل
انا اعطيت اعطي من وقتك وبنهايه اليوم كان
مردود وقتي كفاله خمس ايتام بفلسطين لمده
عام شكرا لهيئه الاعمال الخيريه العالميه
شكرا للعربي